all right gentlemen this is the strength
test to test the durability of your Edge
I'm going to take five chops into this
road barrier with your blade
John you're up you ready absolutely all
right
I'm scared I'm nervous gotta let it out
somehow and deep breathing techniques
are known to work
[Music]
well your blade held up well
there's no chips or dings
but your handle it's awful round
and this guard overhang on my hand is
just enough to start digging in
but good job thank you
Sam you're up next are you ready
I'm ready
foreign
[Music]
no Distortion no rolling blade Edge held
up fine your handle though it's just
that squareness that's right here
instead of being indexed towards the
front it's kind of more indexed towards
the side it kind of wants to be in my
hand like that which makes the whole
knife want to roll on impact although
well done
so Keith you're up are you ready yes sir
all right let's do this
[Music]
okay well there's no distortions on your
Edge no chipping no bending
your handle
pretty rough but the shape is
comfortable I mean it fills my hand
nicely and it's indexed well I know
right where that edge is all in all
nicely done thank you
next up is a sharpness test for that
I'll give you the dug
leadsmiths to test the edge of your
blade and see how sharp it is I will
take your weapon and I will run it
across these cargo straps John you're up
first you ready
to rock
[Music]
okay
okay John you definitely have a Racer's
Edge on your blade right here it cut
cleanly through these cargo straps but
the handle is a little bit rounded for
my hand so it's kind of hard to tell
where it's really indexing at but it
will cut
thank you Sam you're up next you ready
Doug
kinda this man could take me apart and
he wouldn't have to use my knight to do
it
[Music]
first off the indexing of your handle is
very blocky so it affects the way you
handle the blade so as I dragged it and
felt some resistance the weight
distribution and your handle design
started to make the blade turn but for
the first three slices using the belly
of the blade it cut cleanly and for that
sir it'll cut thank you Keith you're up
next you ready yes sir
well Keith off the bats comfortable in
the hand your blade starts to get really
thin so it's razor sharp over here so
initially it cuts all the way through
but it gets thicker in the back and it
was sharp enough to cut through all
three initially
it will cut thank you
bladesmiths
it's time for one of you to leave Forge
Sam
your weapon did not make the cut Sam the
profile of your blade looks great no
issues on your Edge the only issue was
the way you designed your handle caused
it to turn during testing and that's the
reason why we have to let you go
Sam please surrender your weapon
unfortunately my handle making skills is
weren't up to par today that's all right
this experience was an opportunity for
me to learn I came here to make a knife
and I think I succeeded in both